initiating collision
[Music]
[Applause]
you want to train but straining beat
your style
you
you know Jesse told mrs. Bassin very
healthy it's just under Mach 3 heart
rate 100 BPM your vitals are normal
get up Richter is with the you Dooley
honor of allowing me to kill you
you're out of ammo no honor among
thieves and
what did I say you should do is you
encountered speak please tell me you're
staying here
but whatever is hunting me is far worse
than the time race
he consents the speedforce it's trying
to kill me
hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
going to be video all about the
different colors of flash lightning a
lot of you are requesting a video asking
about the differences between the movie
flash and the tv-show flash so I'll
explain everybody from Barry Allen to
Wally West to zoom to the black flash so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be subscriber and leave a comment on
this video be sure to click that bell to
enable alerts there's a whole bunch of
other stuff that's dropping today too so
there are a couple of different colors
of flash lightning there's shades of
yellow moving into red to blue and then
the white lightning of Savitt are it's
all meant to denote how closely they're
connected to the Speed Force how full
they are with speed force so the more
powerful you get the closer your
lightning gets to white so one the color
of your lightning is a function of your
connection to the Speed Force and your
speed but too it's also a really simple
way for non comic-book people to
understand who's fighting who on screen
like if somebody just walked in off the
street and they saw avatar and Barry
start fighting they would know that
Barry's lightning is yellow he wears a
red suit Savitt are looks silver he has
white lightning so when they're running
around as blurs on screen it's easier to
tell them apart largely this is taken
from the comics but there are couple
changes in the comics for instance the
reverse flashes lightning is red because
he uses the negative speed force he has
a slightly different connection to it
than Barry has but he's almost as fast
as Barry TV show reverse flash has red
lightning because he's faster than Barry
so the TV shows just a little bit
different in like Jesse quick for
instance they say that she's almost as
fast as Barry
so her lightning is almost the same
color during the flashpoint episodes we
saw the rival he has a red version of
the lightning he's just a little bit
faster than that version of Wally West
the new Philosopher's Stone Wally West
has more yellow lightning he's not quite
as fast as flashpoint Wally West yet
just because he hadn't been the flash
for as long a period of time and that's
another thing too we'll have to come
back around to wil Savitt are be able to
control him or will he do something
crazy because he got his powers via the
Philosopher's Stone
but during season 2 we met zoom who had
blue lightning because he was so
faster than Barry so it was much closer
to white Sava tar is the fastest
speedster that Barry's ever gone up
against so he has the white lightning
that you see from Ginger Wally West in
the comics who was the fastest version
of the flash so largely they kept that
color scheme in tact but like I said the
second reason for doing it you know one
denoting speed to just denoting who is
fighting who on the page or on the
screen so that's one of the reasons why
when Barry was using the tachyon device
during season 2 to get faster at a much
faster rate his lightning didn't change
colors that much just because they
wanted you to still know that it was
Barry on screen but in reality his
lightning should have changed color
become a more blue shade and it kind of
did just a little bit the movie flash
that a lot of you are asking about why
is his lightning blue that's largely a
Zack Snyder choice but he did explain
that he wanted this version of Barry
Allen to have a much closer connection
to the Speed Force so we haven't met the
other speedsters of the DC EU yet we
largely won't see the reverse flash till
the Flash movie drops in a couple years
so we'll know a little bit better than
but just expect the same thing the
reverse flash of the movies will have a
slightly different shade of color than
Barry Allen he'll have the Blue
Lightning reverse flash of the movies
will probably have the red lightning but
just remember that the movies are
different from the TV shows in the way
they use colors like that there is some
parody but they're meant to be their own
thing so Zack Snyder made that choice
not so much based on what the TV show
was doing so the color schemes of the
movies will be a little bit different
than the color scheme of the TV show but
it all flows from the comics back in the
classic comics it was even more
confusing all the good speedsters had
the exact same color of lightning so
they just tried to change that with the
more modern stuff that they do and that
influences the TV shows they just want
people to have their own identity so
wally west like the young kid flash
wally west in the comics has a red ER
version of the lightning Barry Allen's
is still kind of yellow even though he's
faster it can be a little confusing but
just remember when you're comparing
lightening colors and top speeds of TV
show characters only compare them
against
stuff that the TV show has explained
don't think too much about what happened
in the comics and don't think too much
about what happened in the movies I
think a lot of people like try to take
it all into account and it gets a little
confusing they do that even in the
Marvel Universe with the color of the
Infinity stones they're different colors
in the movies than they are in the
comics and it's very confusing so just
remember the TV shows the movies the
comics they're all just a little bit
different but just to explain the color
change for the black flash I know a lot
of people were wondering because they
changed the emblem color that's mostly
just to make him look different than he
did at the end of last season with zoom
to make him look more like an animal
like he's walking around like a
velociraptor
looking for the reverse-flash but his
lightening is red so by the TV shows
logic that means that he's just as fast
as the reverse-flash meaning that he's
that big of a threat like the
reverse-flash couldn't easily outrun him
which is why he's so afraid but here's
the thing though the TV show actually
changed the black flashes and zooms
emblem even three times within that
final fight that Barry had at the end of
season 2 so that I think which is a
coloring error in post-production so
sometimes the TV show can be a little
inconsistent so try not to read too much
into that
so hopefully that explains lightning
colors just a little bit I'm hoping for
a couple other different colors of the
spectrum as we get more speedsters than
future seasons maybe we can do a version
of the war of light with different
speedsters going to war with each other
but that's all way down the road there's
a new episode posting later tonight
there's an iron fist trailers that just
drop so I'll be doing the iron fist
trailer video next but my flash episode
will post later tonight there'll be a
new round of the flash ring giveaway
going on in that too so get hype there's
going to be awesome
while you wait for that you can click
here to rewatch all those superbowl
trailers and you can click here to learn
all about guardians and infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's iPod I'll see you in the next
video